[Applaudissements]
simplicité le seul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
et ouais on va accueillir d'abord
benjamin castaldi qui est avec nous qui
a passé la nuit avec lui c'est parti
benjamin castaldi avec les narines façon
lancée et puis ce dieu je dirais qui
aujourd'hui travaillent
chez lui il a décidé de venir avec tout
ses exploits benjamin castaldi
mon temps
discours
la méditation entrer des élites
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
venir à weedon oui
celle là
et l'occident
[Musique]
je vienne le chercher j'ai juste de
chercher à tuer ça prend la main
attention attention attention c'est bon
marché et maxime de l'uqam et et comment
toi qu on doit travailler avant centre
c'est notre force à bnp
comme visite génère
[Musique]
gilbert 2
regardez tadjau
c'est tout ça elle c'est la tat qu'on
est tous d'avoir laissé le taureau qui
soit que naguère dit mme jolivet naïve
et jean-michel c'est bon
c'est bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car nous savons
salami jose associés se sont pas mal pas
mal
excusez moi y'a aliaga ya un gars qui
s'est pas fait chier en fait il est venu
en voiture tranquille quoi sérieux il
est venu en voiture tranquille c'est qui
ceux qui bavent apprête loin
[Musique]
m
je sais pas merci bien tu n'as tu donnes
en mai
essai de l'heure
macho
je me lève et boulogne vive la france
ma vie
en vain